the return to normal will be anything
but normal for some ccsd students who
are standing in front of a real
really unique opportunity thanks for
joining us here at 11 i'm denise valdez
and i'm brian loftis superintendent dr
jesus jarrah and other ccsd leaders took
to the field to announce some pretty big
plans
madison kimbrough joining us live from
sierra vista high school with more
madison
yeah you could definitely feel the
energy out here earlier with students
parents and ccsd officials as we learned
the future of high school sports
and performing arts within the district
to take a look
we have prepared for this moment all
year long
when when we shut down a year ago we
started the planning stage
high school athletics are back in action
and so are the performing arts
next friday spring student athletes and
performers will be able to play in games
and perform in shows
once again as a former coach i
understand
how important athletics and the
performing arts
play in the role of the lives of all our
students home team spectators will also
be able to watch in person with
occupancy restrictions in place
social distancing and face coverings
required this wasn't the only big news
of the day
superintendent jarrah also announced a
major partnership
with the las vegas raiders and what
they're calling a jamboree
nine randomly selected high school teams
within the district will be able to play
at allegiant stadium
parents like garvin bushell and his son
gage know this is a once in a lifetime
opportunity to play in legion stadium i
get i tell you they'll work
twice as hard they'll work twice as hard
because everybody wants to teach that i
feel like it's exciting
because you're playing in an nfl stadium
basically
and that's just cool to me i like that a
lot
the jamboree will take place on april
23rd and 24th
and players will have the opportunity to
have scrimmage with their teammates
inside of the stadium for a two hour
window
at this event no spectators will be
allowed
and it should be noted that 33 high
schools within the district have
revamped fields to play on
and as for the teams chosen to play at
allegiant stadium
that will be randomly selected within
the next coming week so look out for
that
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now